Paula Roberts is the English psychic who
is on set to give us a reading right now
I would like Paula for you to give me a
reading on President Trump just the one
card one card one card let's do just one
card we like that
one oh oh
oh what is that I mean I I I do
recognize that I'm I'm at Fox TV I am
a sense of loss let's see President Joe
Biden what will his year look like let's
look at Joe Biden lots and lots and lots
and lots of money lots of money I mean
from
China oh you are
cheeky I I didn't say from where lots of
money a lot of money is very interesting
I mean above okay for whatever is his
normal it's way above that's why when I
say lots wow because I deal with
everybody of every possible um income so
that that that that's lot all right I'm
going to put you in touch with James
comr after this reading
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
please tell us what Jesse waters's year
will look like I've got something more
to tell you about that but
it's an interesting aspect of the young
Dynamic very very very bright person
[Music]